We'd have to start today by talking about
the parable disaster that Donald Trump's
total miss handling of the Kurds in serious
situation has become, and over the weekend
we learned that ISIS fighters are now escaping,
potentially reinvigorating ISIS. Trump has
been thrown into such disarray by this entire
situation that he's now making suggestions
as insane as, Oh, the Kurds are deliberately
freeing ISIS prisoners in order to force the
United States to get back involved or to make
him look bad or whatever. Which is a conspiracy
theory. That is absolutely without evidence.
I mean there's just no evidence for that period.
And it's quite frankly an insane suggestion,
which we'll talk about. And in the background,
of course, if you were Russian president Vladimir
Putin, and you're seeing what Donald Trump
is doing, you were laughing all the way to
the bank. If you are Turkish president Erdogan
and you see what Trump is doing, you are laughing
all the way to the bank.
So let's first just reset here. I mean, this
is just such a huge story. It's just such
a geopolitical disaster that we have to have
all the information and the context. Donald
Trump teased a while ago, months close to
a year maybe at this point that he was going
to get us troops out of Syria. Good. Okay.
Now any good progressive wants to get out
of so-called forever Wars, out of military
engagements with no definite end point, military
engagements of questionable ethics and morality
and practicality and sometimes legality, which
often just fueled the military industrial
complex. So no argument from me or from any
serious progressive in principle, we don't
want us troops involved in any of these places
where it is not necessary legal and all of
the other characteristics that we would want
to see. Now, the concern around Syria was
that there was no particular reason why it
made sense at that point to get out of Syria
specifically because we knew that our presence
was partially to defend the curds and ethnic
group with their own culture and language.
Who have been our allies in the fight against
ISIS. Now, all normal disclaimers apply when
it comes to interventionism. We can't be the
world's police. We can't be committed indefinitely
to these engagements, but there were definitely
places we could have pulled troops from at
the time that made more sense and didn't immediately
and obviously put some of our allies at risk
of death. And of course it just stunk at the
time that it was a move that both Putin and
Erdogan would love for the United States to
make, since they are a combination of anti
Kurdish and pro Bashar Al Assad. So we were
playing right into their hands. Okay. That
was the situation at the time. So then it's
quiet for some months and then last week Trump
says, we're pulling troops from Northern Syria,
but hold on a second. Turkey is going to attack
the Kurds, aren't they?
They're going to get slaughtered. Why are
you doing this? And Trump tweeted in response
to those concerns last week, if Turkey does
things I don't like, I'll destroy their economy.
I believe his exact word was that he would
obliterate their economy within hours. Turkey
starts bombing Kurdish forces in Northern
Syria, and all of a sudden we're wondering
whose idea was this anyway to pull out of
Northern Syria? Because the state department
didn't recommend it. The military didn't recommend
it. We can't find a reasonable answer to that
question other than circumstantially. It plays
right into what authoritarian Erdogan wants.
It plays right into what authoritarian Vladimir
Putin wants. Not good is. That gets us to
this past weekend, the long weekend here in
the United States where we had the Monday
holiday. Uh, and it is a situation of absolute
horror in Northern Syria. A New York times
investigation, by the way, over the weekend,
confirmed that in early may, Russian forces
were bombing hospitals in Syria to hurt the
anti Assad movement.
We know Putin wants to support Assad. Trump
is playing right into that. And the entire
region now has turned into absolute and total
chaos. We've got videos of Turkish proxies
straight up slaughtering people in the streets
of video of people with their hands tied behind
their backs. Kurt Kurds, uh, being shot now,
even if you wanted us troops out, and even
if you wanted us troops out now, which is
a reasonable position to have, there was a
right way to do it. Donald Trump could have
worked with the United nations peacekeeping
forces, maybe with the Syrian government,
I don't know, in advance of just pulling out
and uh, could have negotiated that there has
to be some force there to fill in the gap
that would be created by Donald Trump pulling
forces, pulling troops from Northern Syria.
But of course, that's not how Donald Trump
works. And we now have 700 women and children
link to ISIS who have left a Curtis detention
camp after an airstrike by Turkey dropped
the entire area.
And to just total Bedlam. We have a U S official
now who says that ISIS has a quote, second
lease on life as a result of this completely
boneheaded decision by Donald Trump. The United
States state department is acknowledging that
have written [inaudible], the civilian secretary
general of the future Syria party, which is
the Kurdish movement, has been captured and
killed by Turkish backed Syrian opposition
fighters. Uh, Syrian Arab fighters have been
caught on video, as I mentioned, shooting
Kurdish prisoners with their hands tied behind
their backs. And Donald Trump is suggesting
that it is all a conspiracy. Trump has suggested
that the ISIS fighters who escaped were allowed
to escape by the Kurds in order to pull the
United States back into the region. Trump
tweeting Kurds may be releasing some to get
us involved, easily recaptured by Turkey or
European nations from where many came, but
they should move quickly.
Big sanctions on Turkey coming. Do people
really think we should go to war with NATO
member? Turkey? Never. Ending Wars will end.
And there's a couple of really important things
here. Number one, there's no evidence of what
Donald Trump is proposing here. I mean, there's
just no evidence. He can speculate if he wants,
but we all need to understand that it's dangerous
speculation because there is no evidence that
this is some ploy by the Kurds to release
ISIS. There's no evidence of that. And number
two, we can't fall for this. Never ending
Wars will end thing because that's not actually
what this is about. This is nothing more than
motivated speculative reasoning by Trump to
make himself look less bad. The world community
is perplexed by what Donald Trump has done
here in the United States, ranging from Republicans
all the way to Noam Chomsky believed that
this was the wrong decision and the news couldn't
be worse out of the region.
The Turkish military has recaptured a border
area that had come to be under Kurdish control.
Turkey now has it. How does Moscow, Mitch
McConnell spin this? What will Looney Lindsey
Graham or flimsy Graham as one viewer suggested
I call him do now that he said Trump is going
to have to suffer the consequences of what
happened here. If it all goes wrong and it
has all gone very, very wrong. Donald Trump
has effectively undone the war against ISIS
here. This is potentially potentially a foreign
policy disaster that will rival George W.
Bush. His decision to get into the Iraq war
after a dozen and a half Saudi nationals attacked
us on nine 11. I don't want to be hyperbolic.
I'm not saying it is that yet, but it has
the potential to be, and Donald Trump is in
his own world of conspiracy theories and tweeting
as people are getting slaughtered within a
context of ISIS being reinvigorated.
Maybe the, the, maybe it will rise to the
level of, uh, of a George W. Bush foreign
policy blender. Certainly the biggest foreign
policy blunder of Trump's presidency so far.